destiny is not just a thing that you you
take home you play in the drop like
we're building experience that you can
live in we learn to people ways to own
the world to say i was there day one the
game itself obviously is your portal
into another universe but doesn't just
stop there so we've got three editions
we've got our ghost edition a guardian
digital edition and the limited edition
one of the really cool things about the
limited edition is when you open it up
you get sort of sci-fi element the
steelbook and you get sort of the
fantasy elements or leather bound book
we have things that all tell different
stories photographs from the travelers
first visit ashes from the Cosmodrome we
also have this really wonderful arms and
armaments book staunton armament focus
is like a field guide this is something
that someone took time and care in this
doomed City to put together within the
official text of the field guys as
information you need to set up the
foundation of the world but then the
handwritten notes are littered with
secrets and riddles that you'll be able
to unfold as you actually step into the
game we scrutinized every little line
every little embossing but the print
techniques to make sure it felt unique
but also really told the story of a game
the limited edition is packed into the
ghost addition when you open the top I'm
gonna see the ghost your companion in
the game it's not just the regular
ghosts you get in the game as a special
skin a special shell so everybody else
we had a white one go get those red one
it's such a direct companion a game of
direct relationship you have with the
ghost all throughout the campaigns we
thought when I bring that to life we're
not allow players to have that with them
in the real world whoa hello turn
affects how true we're also giving you a
ship variant did you see you
single-mode is you're forming up your
fire teams going off into competitive
multiplayer we also have a player emblem
which is super exclusive other players
will see it and ask you where you got it
I wasn't talking to you data like i
watch goose actually so if they want
that go shell if they want that player
ship they want the emblem we're actually
adding them as well in the digital
Guardian addition each collector's
edition comes with our expansion pass
which includes expansion pack 1 the dark
below expansion pack to house of wolves
these aren't just map packs they expand
on the story at new weapons and gear at
new content for everybody you will
recover the reality as you play pieces
of the puzzle will start to click
together realities will become crystal
clear or or they won't and you'll have
to wait for it unfold this is a living
world destiny is built to be in
ever-expanding universe people who love
immersing themselves in the world are
really going to find something great in
any of these additions going back in
that box
you